The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hey, everybody.
You ready to learn
some algorithms?
Yeah!
Let's do it.
I'm Eric Domain.
You can call me Eric.
And the last class, we
sort of jumped into things.
We studied peak
finding and looked
at a bunch of algorithms
for peak finding
on your problem set.
You've already
seen a bunch more.
And in this class, we're going
to do some more algorithms.
Don't worry.
That will be at the end.
We're going to talk about
another problem, document
distance, which will be a
running example for a bunch
of topics that we
cover in this class.
But before we go there, I wanted
to take a step back and talk
about, what actually
is an algorithm?
What is an algorithm
allowed to do?
And also deep philosophical
questions like, what is time?
What is the running
time of an algorithm?
How do we measure it?
And what are the rules the game?
For fun, I thought I
would first mention
where the word comes
from, the word algorithm.
It comes from this guy,
a little hard to spell.
Al-Khwarizmi, who is sort
of the father of algebra.
He wrote this book called "The
Compendious Book on Calculation
by Completion and
Balancing" back in the day.
And it was in
particular about how
to solve linear and
quadratic equations.
So the beginning of algebra.
I don't think he invented
those techniques.
But he was sort of
the textbook writer
who wrote sort of how
people solved them.
And you can think
of how to solve
those equations as
early algorithms.
First, you take this number.
You multiply by this.
You add it or you reduce
to squares, whatever.
So that's where the word
algebra comes from and also
where the word
algorithm comes from.
There aren't very many
words with these roots.
So there you go.
Some fun history.
What's an algorithm?
I'll start with sort of
some informal definitions
and then the point
of this lecture.
And the idea of a
model of computation
is to formally specify
what an algorithm is.
I don't want to get super
technical and formal here,
but I want to give
you some grounding
so when we write Python code,
when we write pseudocode,
we have some idea what
things actually cost.
This is a new lecture.
We've never done
this before in 006.
But I think it's important.
So at a high level,
you can think
of an algorithm is just
a-- I'm sure you've
seen the definition before.
It's a way to define computation
or computational procedure
for solving some problem.
So whereas computer
code, I mean,
it could just be running
in the background
all the time doing whatever.
An algorithm we think
of as having some input
and generating some output.
Usually, it's to
solve some problem.
You want to know is this
number prime, whatever.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you turn up
the volume for your mic?
PROFESSOR: This microphone does
not feed into the AV system.
So I shall just talk louder, OK?
And quiet the set, please.
OK, so that's an algorithm.
You take some input.
You run it through.
You compute some output.
Of course, computer
code can do this too.
An algorithm is basically
the mathematical analog
of a computer program.
So if you want to reason about
what computer programs do,
you translate it into
the world algorithms.
And vice versa, you want to
solve some problem-- first,
you usually develop an
algorithm using mathematics,
using this class.
And then you convert
it into computer code.
And this class is about
that transition from one
to the other.
You can draw a picture
of sort of analogs.
So an algorithm is a
mathematical analog
of a computer program.
A computer program is built on
top of a programming language.
And it's written in a
programming language.
The mathematical analog
of a programming language,
what we write algorithms
in, usually we
write them in pseudocode,
which is basically
another fancy word for
structured English,
good English, whatever
you want to say.
Of course, you could use
another natural language.
But the idea is, you need to
express that algorithm in a way
that people can understand
and reason about formally.
So that's the structured part.
Pseudocode means lots
of different things.
It's just sort of an abstract
how you would write down
formal specification
without necessarily being
able to actually run
it on a computer.
Though there's a particular
pseudocode in your textbook
which you probably
could run on a computer.
A lot of it, anyway.
But you don't have
to use that version.
It just makes sense to humans
who do the mathematics.
OK, and then ultimately, this
program runs on a computer.
You all have computers,
probably in your pockets.
There's an analog of a computer
in the mathematical world.
And that is the
model of computation.
And that's sort of the focus of
the first part of this lecture.
Model of computation says what
your computer is allowed to do,
what it can do in
constant time, basically?
And that's what I want
to talk about here.
So the model of computation
specifies basically
what operations you
can do in an algorithm
and how much they cost.
This is the what is time.
So for each
operation, we're going
to specify how
much time it costs.
Then the algorithm does
a bunch of operations.
They're combined together
with control flow,
for loops, if statements,
stuff like that which we're not
going to worry about too much.
But obviously, we'll
use them a lot.
And what we count is how much
do each of the operations cost.
You add them up.
That is the total cost
of your algorithm.
So in particular, we
care mostly in this class
about running time.
Each operation has a time cost.
You add those up.
That's running time
of the algorithm.
OK, so let's-- I'm going to
cover two models of computation
which you can just think of
as different ways of thinking.
You've probably seen
them in some sense
as-- what you call them?
Styles of programming.
Object oriented style of
programming, more assembly
style of programming.
There's lots of different
styles of programming languages
which I'm not going
to talk about here.
But you've see analogs if
you've seen those before.
And these models
really give you a way
of structuring your
thinking about how
you write an algorithm.
So they are the random access
machine and the pointer
machine.
So we'll start with random
access machine, also known
as the RAM.
Can someone tell me what
else RAM stands for?
AUDIENCE: Random Access Memory?
PROFESSOR: Random Access Memory.
So this is both confusing
but also convenience.
Because RAM simultaneously
stands for two things
and they mean almost the
same thing, but not quite.
So I guess that's more
confusing than useful.
But there you go.
So we have random access memory.
Oh, look at that.
Fits perfectly.
And so we're thinking,
this is a real--
this is-- random access memory
is over here in real computer
land.
That's like, D-RAM
SD-RAM, whatever--
the things you buy and stick
into your motherboard, your GP,
or whatever.
And over here, the mathematical
analog of-- so here's,
it's a RAM.
Here, it's also a RAM.
Here, it's a random
access machine.
access memory.
It's technical detail.
But the idea is, if you look
at RAM that's in your computer,
it's basically a
giant array, right?
You can go from zero
to, I don't know.
A typical chip these days is
like four gigs in one thing.
So you can go from
zero to four gigs.
You can access anything in the
middle there in constant time.
To access something, you
need to know where it is.
That's random access memory.
So that's an array.
So I'll just draw a big picture.
Here's an array.
Now, RAM is usually
organized by words.
So these are a
machine word, which
we're going to
put in this model.
And then there's address zero,
address one, address two.
This is the fifth word.
And just keeps going.
You can think of
this as infinite.
Or the amount that
you use, that's
the space of your algorithm, if
you care about storage space.
So that's basically it.
OK, now how do we-- this is
the memory side of things.
How do we actually
compute with it?
It's very simple.
We just say, in constant time,
an algorithm can basically
read in or load a constant
number of words from memory,
do a constant number of
computations on them,
and then write them out.
It's usually called store.
OK, it needs to know
where these words are.
It accesses them by address.
And so I guess I
should write here
you have a constant number of
registers just hanging around.
So you load some
words into registers.
You can do some computations
on those registers.
And then you can
write them back,
storing them in
locations that are
specified by your registers.
So you've ever done
assembly programming,
this is what assembly
programming is like.
And it can be rather annoying to
write algorithms in this model.
But in some sense,
it is reality.
This is how we think
about computers.
If you ignore
things like caches,
this is an accurate
model of computation
that loading,
computing, and storing
all take roughly the
same amount of time.
They all take constant time.
You can manipulate a
whole word at a time.
Now, what exactly is a word?
You know, computers these days,
it's like 32 bits or 64 bits.
But we like to be a
little bit more abstract.
A word is w bits.
It's slightly annoying.
And most of this class, we won't
really worry about what w is.
We'll assume that
we're given as input
a bunch of things
which are words.
So for example, peak finding.
We're given a matrix of numbers.
We didn't really say whether
they're integers or floats
or what.
We don't worry about that.
We just think of
them as words and we
assume that we can
manipulate those words.
In particular, given two
numbers, we can compare them.
Which is bigger?
And so we can determine,
is this cell in the matrix
a peak by comparing it with
its neighbors in constant time.
We didn't say why it was
constant time to do that.
But now you kind of know.
If those things are
all words and you
can manipulate a constant number
of words in constant time,
you can tell whether a number
is a peak in constant time.
Some things like w should be at
least log the size of memory.
Because my word should
be able to specify
an index into this array.
And we might use that someday.
But basically, don't
worry about it.
Words are words.
Words come in as inputs.
You can manipulate
them and you don't
have to worry about
it for the most part.
In unit four of
this class, we're
going to talk about, what if we
have really giant integers that
don't fit in a word?
How do we manipulate them?
How do we add them,
multiply them?
So that's another topic.
But most of this
class, we'll just
assume everything we're
given is one word.
And it's easy to compute on.
So this is a realistic
model, more or less.
And it's a powerful one.
But a lot of the
time, a lot of code
just doesn't use
arrays-- doesn't need it.
Sometimes we need arrays,
sometimes we don't.
Sometimes you feel like a
nut, sometimes you don't.
So it's useful to think about
somewhat more abstract models
that are not quite as
powerful but offer a simpler
way of thinking about things.
For example, in
this model there's
no dynamic memory allocation.
You probably know you could
implement dynamic memory
allocation because
real computers do it.
But it's nice to
think about a model
where that's taken
care of for you.
It's kind of like a higher
level programming abstraction.
So the one is useful in this
class is the pointer machine.
This basically corresponds to
object oriented programming
in a simple, very
simple version.
So we have dynamically
allocated objects.
And an object has a
constant number of fields.
And a field is going to
be either a word-- so you
can think of this
as, for example,
storing an integer, one
of the input objects
or something you computed on it
or a counter, all these sorts
of things-- or a pointer.
And that's where pointer
machine gets its name.
A pointer is something that
points to another object
or has a special value
null, also known as nil,
also known as none in Python.
OK, how many people have
heard about pointers before?
Who hasn't?
Willing to admit it?
OK, only a few.
That's good.
You should have seen pointers.
You may have heard
them called references.
Modern languages these days
don't call them pointers
because pointers are scary.
But there's a very subtle
difference between them.
And this model actually
really is references.
But for whatever reason, it's
called a pointer machine.
It doesn't matter.
The point is, you've
seem linked lists I hope.
And linked lists have a
bunch of fields in each node.
Maybe you've got a pointer
to the previous element,
a pointer to the next
element, and some value.
So here's a very
simple linked list.
This is what you'd call a
doubly linked list because it
has previous and next pointers.
So the next pointer
points to this node.
The previous pointer
Next pointer points to null.
points to null, let's say.
So that's a two node
doubly linked list.
You presume we have a pointer
to the head of the list,
maybe a pointer to the
tail of list, whatever.
So this is a structure
in the pointer machine.
It's a data structure.
In Python, you might
call this a named tuple,
or it's just an object
with three attributes,
I guess, they're
called in Python.
So here we have the value.
That's a word like an integer.
And then some things
can be pointers
that point to other nodes.
And you can create a new node.
You can destroy a node.
That's the dynamic
memory allocation.
In this model, yeah,
pointers are pointers.
You can't touch them.
Now, you can implement this
model in a random access
machine.
A pointer becomes an index
into this giant table.
And that's more like
the pointers in C
if you've ever
written C programs.
Because then you
can take a pointer
and you can add one to it and
go to the next thing after that.
In this model, you can
just follow a pointer.
That's all you can do.
OK, following a pointer
costs constant time.
Changing one of these
fields costs constant time.
All the usual things you might
imagine doing to these objects
take constant time.
So it's actually a weaker
model than this one.
Because you could
implement a pointer machine
with a random access machine.
But it offers a different
way of thinking.
A lot of data structures
are built this way.
Cool.
So that's the theory side.
What I'd like to talk about
next is actually in Python,
what's a reasonable
model of what's going on?
So these are old models.
This goes back to the '80s.
This one probably '80s or '70s.
So they've been
around a long time.
People have used them forever.
Python is obviously much
more recent, at least
modern versions of Python.
And it's the model of
computation in some sense
that we use in this class.
Because we're implementing
everything in Python.
And Python offers both a random
access machine perspective
because it has arrays, and
it offers a pointer machine
perspective because
it has references,
because it has pointers.
So you can do either one.
But it also has a
lot of operations.
It doesn't just have load
and store and follow pointer.
It's got things
like sort and append
and concatenation of two
lists and lots of things.
And each of those has a
cost associated with them.
So whereas the random access
machine and pointer machine,
they're theoretical models.
They're designed
to be super simple.
So it's clear that everything
you do takes constant time.
In Python, some of the
operations you can do
take a lot of time.
Some of the operations in Python
take exponential time to do.
And you've got to know when
you're writing your algorithms
down either thinking in a Python
model or your implementing
your algorithms
in actual Python,
which operations are
fast and which are slow.
And that's what I'd like to
spend the next few minutes on.
There's a lot of operations.
I'm not going to
cover all of them.
But we'll cover
more in recitation.
And there's a whole
bunch in my notes.
I won't get to all of them.
So in Python, you can do
random access style things.
In Python, arrays
are called lists,
which is super confusing.
But there you go.
A list in Python is an
array in real world.
It's a super cool
array, of course?
And you can think
of it as a list.
But in terms implementation,
it's implemented as an array.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I thought
that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You thought Python
links lists were linked lists.
That's why it's so confusing.
In fact, they are not.
In, say, scheme, back in the
days when we taught scheme,
lists are linked lists.
And it's very different.
So when you do-- I'll
give an operation here.
You have a list L, and you
do something like this.
L is a list object.
This takes constant time.
In a linked list, it
would take linear time.
Because we've got a scan to
position I, scan to position J,
add 5, and store.
But conveniently in Python,
this takes constant time.
And that's important to know.
I know that the terminology
is super confusing.
But blame the benevolent
dictator for life.
On the other hand, you can do
style two, pointer machine,
using object oriented
programming, obviously.
I'll just mention
that I'm not really
worrying about methods here.
Because methods are just sort of
a way of thinking about things,
not super important
from a cost standpoint.
If your object has a constant
number of attributes--
it can't have like
a million attributes
or can't have n
executes-- then it
fits into this
pointer machine model.
So if you have an
object that only
has like three things or
10 things or whatever,
that's a pointer machine.
You can think of
manipulating that object
as taking constant time.
If you are screwing around
the object's dictionary
and doing lots of
crazy things, then you
have to be careful about
whether this remains true.
But as long as you only
have a reasonable number
of attributes, this
is all fair game.
And so if you do something like,
if you're implementing a linked
list, Python I
checked still does not
have built-in linked lists.
They're pretty easy
to build, though.
You have a pointer.
And you just say
x equals x.next.
That takes constant time
because accessing this field
in an object of constant
size takes constant time.
And we don't care what
these constants are.
That's the beauty of algorithms.
Because we only care
about scalability with n.
There's no n here.
This takes constant time.
No matter how big
your linked list
is or no matter how
many objects you have,
these are constant time.
OK, let's do some
harder ones, though.
In general, the
idea is, if you take
an operation like L.append--
so you have a list.
And you want to append
some item to the list.
It's an array, though.
So think about it.
The way to figure out
how much does this cost
is to think about
how it's implemented
in terms of these
basic operations.
So these are your sort of
the core concept time things.
Most everything can be reduced
to thinking about this.
But sometimes,
it's less obvious.
L.apend is a little
tricky to think about.
Because basically, you
have an array of some size.
And now you want to make
an array one larger.
And the obvious way to do that
is to allocate a new array
and copy all the elements.
That would take linear time.
Python doesn't do that.
What does it do?
Stay tuned for lecture eight.
It does something
called table doubling.
It's a very simple idea.
You can almost get
guess it from the title.
And if you go to lecture--
is it eight or nine?
Nine, sorry.
You'll see how
this can basically
be done in constant time.
There's a slight catch,
but basically, think of it
as a constant time operation.
Once we have that,
and so this is
why you should take
this class so you'll
understand how Python works.
This is using an algorithmic
concept that was invented,
I don't know, decades
ago, but is a simple thing
that we need to do to solve
lots of other problems.
So it's cool.
There's a lot of features in
Python that use algorithms.
And that's kind of
why I'm telling you.
All right, so let's
do another one.
A little easier.
What if I want to
concatenate two lists?
You should know in Python this
is a non-destructive operation.
You basically take a copy of
L1 and L2 and concatenate them.
Of course, they're arrays.
The way to think about
this is to re-implement it
as Python code.
This is the same
thing as saying, well,
L is initially empty.
And then for every item
x and L1, L.append(x).
And a lot of the times in
documentation for Python,
you see this sort of here's
what it means, especially
in the fancier features.
They give sort of an equivalent
simple Python, if you will.
This doesn't use
any fancy operations
that we haven't seen already.
So now we know this
takes constant time.
The append, this append,
And so the amount of
time here is basically
order the length of L1.
And the time here is
order the length of L2.
And so in total,
it's order-- I'm
going to be careful and
say 1 plus length of L1
plus length of L2.
The 1 plus is just in
case these are both 0.
It still takes constant time
to build an initial list.
OK, so there are a
bunch of operations
that are written in these notes.
I'm not going to go
through all of them
because they're tedious.
But a lot of you, could just
expand out code like this.
And it's very easy to analyze.
Whereas you just
look at plus, you
think, oh, plus
is constant time.
And plus is constant
time if this is a word
and this is a word.
But these are entire
data structures.
And so it's not constant time.
All right.
There are more subtle
fun ones to think about.
Like, if I want to know is x in
the list, how does that happen?
Any guesses?
There's an operator
in Python called
in-- x in L. How long
do you think this takes?
Altogether?
Linear, yeah.
Linear time.
In the worst case,
you're going to have
to scan through the whole list.
Lists aren't necessarily sorted.
We don't know
anything about them.
So you've got to just
scan through and test
for every item.
Is x equal to that item?
And it's even worse if
equal equals costs a lot.
So if x is some really
complicated thing,
you have to take
that into account.
OK, blah, blah, blah.
OK, another fun one.
This is like a pop quiz.
How long's it take to
compute the length of a list?
Constant.
Yeah, luckily, if you
didn't know anything,
you'd have to scan through
the list and count the items.
But in Python, lists
are implemented
with a counter built in.
It always stores the
list at the beginning--
stores the length of the
list at the beginning.
So you just look it up.
This is instantaneous.
It's important, though.
That can matter.
All right.
Let's do some more.
What if I want to sort a list?
How long does that take?
N log n where n is the
length of the list.
Technically times the time
to compare two items, which
usually we're just
sorting words.
And so this is constant time.
If you look at Python
sorting algorithm,
it uses a comparison sort.
This is the topic of lectures
three and four and seven.
But in particular,
the very next lecture,
we will see how this is
done in n log n time.
And that is using algorithms.
All right, let's
go to dictionaries.
Python called dicts.
And these let you do things.
They're a generalization
of lists in some sense.
Instead of putting just an
index here, an integer between 0
and the length minus 1, you
can put an arbitrary key
and store a value, for example.
How long does this take?
I'm not going to ask you
because, it's not obvious.
In fact, this is one of the
most important data structures
in all of computer science.
It's called a hash table.
And it is the topic of
lectures eight through 10.
So stay tuned for how to
do this in constant time,
how to be able to
store an arbitrary key,
get it back out
in constant time.
This is assuming the
key is a single word.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it first check to
see whether the key is already
in the dictionary?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it will
clobber any existing key.
There's also, you
know, you can test
whether a key is
in the dictionary.
That also takes constant time.
You can delete something
from the dictionary.
All the usual-- dealing with
a single key in dictionaries,
obviously dictionary.update,
that involves a lot of keys.
That doesn't take some time.
How long does it take?
Well, you write out a
for loop and count them.
AUDIENCE: But how can you
see whether [INAUDIBLE]
dictionary in constant time?
PROFESSOR: How do you do
this in constant time?
Come to lecture
eight through 10.
I should say a
slight catch, which
is this is constant time
with high probability.
It's a randomized algorithm.
It doesn't always
take constant time.
It's always correct.
But sometimes, very rarely,
it takes a little more
than constant time.
And I'm going to
abbreviate this WHP.
And we'll see more what
that means mostly, actually,
in 6046.
But we'll see a fair amount
in 6006 on how this works
and how it's possible.
It's a big area of research.
A lot of people work on hashing.
It's very cool and
it's super useful.
If you write any code these
days, you use a dictionary.
It's the way to solve problems.
I'm basically using
Python is a platform
to advertise the rest of the
class you may have noticed.
Not every topic we cover in
this class is already in Python,
but a lot of them are.
So we've got table doubling.
We've got dictionaries.
We've got sorting.
Another one is longs, which
are long integers in Python
through version two.
And this is the
topic of lecture 11.
And so for fun, if I have
two integers x and y,
and let's say one of them
is this many words long
and the other one is
this many words long,
how long do you think
it takes to add them?
Guesses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Plus?
Times?
Plus is the answer.
You can do it in that much time.
If you think about the
grade school algorithm
for adding really big
multi-digit numbers,
it'll only take that much time.
Multiplication is a
little bit harder, though.
If you look at the
grade school algorithm,
it's going to be x times y--
it's quadratic time not so
good.
The algorithm that's
implemented in Python
is x plus y to the
log base 2 of 3.
By the way, I always write
LG to mean log base 2.
Because it only has two
letters, so OK, this is 2.
Log base 2 of 3 is about 1.6.
So while the straightforward
algorithm is basically
x plus y squared, this one
is x plus y to the 1.6 power,
a little better than quadratic.
And the Python developers
found that was faster
than grade school
multiplication.
And so that's what
they implemented.
And that is something we
will cover in lecture 11,
how to do that.
It's pretty cool.
There are faster
algorithms, but this
is one that works
quite practically.
One more.
Heap queue, this is in the
Python standard library
and implements something
called the heap, which
will be in lecture four.
So, coming soon to a
classroom near you.
All right, enough advertisement.
That gives you some idea of
the model of computation.
There's a whole bunch more in
these notes which are online.
Go check them out.
And some of them, we'll
cover in recitation tomorrow.
I'd like to-- now that we are
sort of comfortable for what
costs what in Python, I
want to do a real example.
So last time, we
did peak finding.
We're going to have
another example which
is called document distance.
So let's do that.
Any questions before we go on?
All right.
So document distance problem
is, I give you two documents.
I'll call them D1 D2.
And I want to compute the
distance between them.
And the first question
is, what does that mean?
What is this distance function?
Let me first tell
you some motivations
for computing document distance.
Let's say you're
Google and you're
cataloging the entire web.
You'd like to know when two web
pages are basically identical.
Because then you store less
and because you present it
differently to the user.
You say, well,
there's this page.
And there's lots
of extra copies.
But you just need--
here's the canonical one.
Or you're Wikipedia.
And I don't know if you've
ever looked at Wikipedia.
There's a list of all
mirrors of Wikipedia.
There's like millions of them.
And they find them by hand.
But you could do that
using document distance.
Say, are these
basically identical
other than like some
stuff at the-- junk
at the beginning or the end?
Or if you're teaching this
class and you want to detect,
are two problem sets cheating?
Are they identical?
We do this a lot.
I'm not going to tell you
what distance function we use.
Because that would
defeat the point.
It's not the one
we cover in class.
But we use automated tests
for whether you're cheating.
I've got some more.
Web search.
Let's say you're Google again.
And you want to
implement searching.
Like, I give you three words.
I'm searching for
introduction to algorithms.
You can think of
introduction to algorithms
as a very short document.
And you want to test
whether that document is
similar to all the other
documents on the web.
And the one that's most
similar, the one that
has the small
distance, that's maybe
what you want to put at the top.
That's obviously not
what Google does.
But it's part of what it does.
So that's why you might care.
It's partly also
just a toy problem.
It lets us illustrate
a lot of the techniques
that we develop in this class.
All right, I'm going
to think of a document
as a sequence of words.
Just to be a little
bit more formal,
what do I mean by document?
And a word is just
going to be a string
of alphanumeric
characters-- A through Z
and zero through nine.
OK, so if I have a
document which you also
think of as a string
and you basically
delete all the white space and
punctuation all the other junk
that's in there.
This Everything in between
those, those are the words.
That's a simple definition
of decomposing documents
into words.
And now we can think
of about what--
I want to know whether
D1 and D2 are similar.
And I've thought
about my document
as a collection of words.
Maybe they're similar if they
share a lot of words in common.
So that's the idea.
Look at shared words
and use that to define
document distance.
This is obviously only one
way to define distance.
It'll be the way we
do it in this class.
But there are lots of
other possibilities.
So I'm going to
think of a document.
It's a sequence of words.
But I could also think
of it as a vector.
So if I have a document D and
I have a word W, this D of W
is going to be the
number of times
that word occurs
in the document.
So, number of recurrences
W in the document D.
So it's a number.
It's an integer.
Non-negative integer.
Could be 0.
Could be one.
Could be a million.
I think of this
as a giant vector.
A vector is indexed
by all words.
And for each of them,
there's some frequency.
Of lot of them are zero.
And then some of them have some
positive number occurrences.
You could think
of every document
is as being one of these
plots in this common axis.
There's infinitely
many words down here.
So it's kind of a big axis.
But it's one way to
draw the picture.
OK, so for example, take two
very important documents.
Everybody likes cats and dogs.
So these are two word documents.
And so we can draw them.
Because there's only three
different words here,
we can draw them in
three dimensional space.
Beyond that, it's a
little hard to draw.
So we have, let's say,
which one's the-- let's say
this one's the-- makes
it easier to draw.
So there's going to be
just zero here and one.
For each of the axes, let's say
this is dog and this is cat.
OK, so the cat has won the--
it has one cat and no dog.
So it's here.
It's a vector
pointing out there.
The dog you've got
basically pointing there.
OK, so these are two vectors.
So how do I measure how
different two vectors are?
Any suggestions from
vector calculus?
AUDIENCE: Inner product?
PROFESSOR: Inner product?
Yeah, that's good suggestion.
Any others.
OK, we'll go with inner product.
I like inner product,
also known as dot product.
Just define that quickly.
So we could-- I'm going
to call this D prime
because it's not what
we're going to end up with.
We could think of this as
the dot product of D1 and D2,
also known as the sum over all
words of D1 of W times D2 of W.
So for example, you take the
dot product of these two guys.
Those match.
So you get one point there,
cat and dog multiplied by zero.
So you don't get much there.
So this is some
measure of distance.
But it's a measure of,
actually, of commonality.
So it would be sort of
inverse distance, sorry.
If you have a high
dot product, you
have a lot of things in common.
Because a lot of these
things didn't be--
wasn't zero times something.
It's actually a positive number
times some positive number.
If you have a lot of shared
words, than that looks good.
The trouble of this is if
I have a long document--
say, a million words--
and it's 99% in common
with another document
that's a million words long,
it's still-- it
looks super similar.
Actually, I need to do
it the other way around.
Let's say it's a million words
long and half of the words
are in common.
So not that many,
but a fair number.
Then I have a score
of like 500,000.
And then I have two documents
which are, say, 100 words long.
And they're identical.
Their score is maybe only 100.
So even though
they're identical,
it's not quite scale invariant.
So it's not quite
a perfect measure.
Any suggestions for
how to fix this?
This, I think, is
a little trickier.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Divide by the
length of the vectors?
PROFESSOR: Divide by the
length of the vectors.
I think that's worth a pillow.
Haven't done any pillows yet.
Sorry about that.
So, divide by the
length of vector.
That's good.
I'm going to call
this D double prime.
Still not quite
the right answer.
Or not-- no, it's pretty good.
It's pretty good.
So here, the length
of the vectors
is the number of
words that occur
in them This is pretty cool.
But does anyone
recognize this formula?
Angle, yeah.
It's a lot like the angle
between the two vectors.
It's just off by an arc cos.
This is the cosine of the
angle between the two vectors.
And I'm a geometer.
I like geometry.
So if you take arc
cos of that thing,
that's a well established
distance metric.
This goes back to '75,
if you can believe it,
back when people-- early
days of document, information
retrieval, way before
the web, people
were still working
on this stuff.
So it's a natural measure of the
angle between the two vectors.
If it's 0, they're
basically identical.
If it's 90 degrees, they're
really, really different.
And so that gives you a nice way
to compute document distance.
The question is, how do we
actually compute that measure?
Now that we've come up with
something that's reasonable,
how do I actually
find this value?
I need to compute these
vectors-- the number
of recurrences of each
word in the document.
And I need you compute
the dot product.
And then I need to divide.
That's really easy.
So, dot product--
and I also need
to decompose a document
to a list of words.
So there are three
things I need to do.
Let me write them down.
So a sort of algorithm.
There's one, split a
document into words.
Second is compute
word frequencies,
how many times
each word appears.
This is the document vectors .
And then the third step is
to compute the dot product.
Let me tell you a little
bit about how each of those
is done.
Some of these will be covered
more in future lectures.
I want to give you an overview.
There's a lot of ways to
do each of these steps.
If you look at the--
next to the lecture
notes for this lecture two,
there's a bunch of code
and a bunch of data
examples of documents--
big corpuses of text.
And you can run,
I think, there are
eight different
algorithms for it.
And let me give you--
actually, why don't I
cut to the chase a
little bit and tell you
about the run times of these
different implementations
of this same algorithms.
There are lots of sort of
versions of this algorithm.
We implement it a whole bunch.
Every semester I teach this, I
change them a little bit more,
add a few more variants.
So version one, on
a particular pair
of documents which is like a
megabyte-- not very much text--
it takes 228.1
seconds-- super slow.
Pathetic.
Then we do a little bit
of algorithmic tweaking.
We get down to 164 seconds.
Then we get to 123 seconds.
Then we get down to 71 seconds.
Then we get down
to 18.3 seconds.
And then we get to 11.5 seconds.
Then we get to 1.8 seconds.
Then we get to 0.2 seconds.
So factor of 1,000.
This is just in Python.
2/10 of a second to
process a megabytes.
It's all right.
It's getting reasonable.
This is not so reasonable.
Some of these improvements
are algorithmic.
Some of them are
just better coding.
So there's improving
the constant factors.
But if you look at
larger and larger texts,
this will become
even more dramatic.
Because a lot of these
were improvements
from quadratic time algorithms
to linear and log n algorithms.
And so for a megabyte, yeah,
it's a reasonable improvement.
But if you look at a gigabyte,
it'll be a huge improvement.
There will be no comparison.
In fact, there will
be no comparison.
Because this one
will never finish.
So the reason I ran
such a small example
so I could have patience
to wait for this one.
But this one you could run
on the bigger examples.
All right, so where do
I want to go from here?
Five minutes.
I want to tell you about
some of those improvements
and some of the algorithms here.
Let's start with
this very simple one.
How would you split a
document into words in Python?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Iterate through the document,
[INAUDIBLE] the dictionary?
PROFESSOR: Iterate
through the-- that's
actually how we do number two.
OK, we can talk about that one.
Iterate through the
words in the document
and put it in a dictionary.
Let's say, count of
word plus equals 1.
This would work if count
is something called a count
dictionary if you're
super Pythonista.
Otherwise, you have to check,
is the word in the dictionary?
If not, set it to one.
If it is there, add one to it.
But I think you know
what this means.
This will count the
number of words--
this will count the frequency
of each word in the dictionary.
And becomes dictionaries
run in constant time
with high probability--
this will take order--
well, cheating a little bit.
Because words can
be really long.
And so to reduce a word
down to a machine word
could take order the
length of the word time.
To a little more
precise, this is
going to be the
sum of the lengths
of the words in the
document, which is also
known as a length of
the document, basically.
So this is good.
This is linear time
with high probability.
OK, that's a good algorithm.
That is introduced
in algorithm four.
So we got a significant boost.
There are other ways to do this.
For example, you
could sort the words
and then run through
the sorted list
and count, how many do you
get in a row for each one?
If it's sorted, you
can count-- I mean,
all the identical words are
put right next to each other.
So it's easy to count them.
And that'll run almost as fast.
That was one of
these algorithms.
OK, so that's a couple
different ways to do that.
Let's go back to
this first step.
How would you split a document
into words in the first place?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Search circulated
spaces and then [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Run through
though the string.
And every time you see anything
that's not alphanumeric,
start a new word.
OK, that would run
in linear time.
That's a good answer.
So it's not hard.
If you're a fancy Pythonista,
you might do it like this.
Remember my Reg Exes.
This will find all the
words in a document.
Trouble is, in general,
re takes exponential time.
So if you think about
algorithms, be very careful.
Unless you know how
re is implemented,
this probably will
run in linear time.
But it's not obvious at all.
Do anything fancy with
regular expressions.
If you don't know what this
means, don't worry about it.
Don't use it.
If you know about it, be
very careful in this class
when you use re.
Because it's not
always linear time.
But there is an easy
algorithm for this,
which is just scan through
and look for alpha numerics.
String them together.
It's good.
There's a few other
algorithms here in the notes.
You should check them out.
And for fun, look at this code
and see how small differences
make dramatic difference
in performance.
Next class will
be about sorting.